what's going on everyone happy New Year
a new look to the 2023 season and from
all of us at geek culture happy 2023 and
we're gonna kick things off talking
about what could be the most Pro app on
the iPad thus far from Blackmagic design
DaVinci Resolve you are into editing
videos like we do here on the channel
where your home videos or for work and
you want a pro video app well it's not
gonna be Final Cut Pro as of yet it's
gonna be da Vinci resolve now I've been
testing this for the past few weeks I
had the testified version of it I've
been using the retail version as well on
the M1 and M2 iPad Pro which I have the
M2 right here in front of me and I've
got some thoughts on it some good things
and some not so good things anyway big
thanks to Blackmagic design Singapore
who are very kind enough to walk me
through some of the settings and some of
the features of this new app and they
also did highlight some of the things
they will be improving on and some
things that they have taken notes on as
well so that let's get down to talking
about DaVinci Resolve for the iPad so
this app is not going to be for the
novice editor out there or color grader
okay this is a industry standard in
Hollywood
and around the world in various
different applications if you are let's
say AI Movie Editor or even let's say a
lumafusion editor and you want to
transition to DaVinci Resolve I would
highly recommend that you download the
free version on Mac or on PC and start
from there because that design language
that UI will translate over to the iPad
and they do a beautiful job with that
however this is a big but here is that
on the iPad when you hover over any icon
as of right now there is no explanation
of what any of these icons are none I
brought this up to Blackmagic design
they agreed that this is something they
need to add into the iPad app will they
do that or not I have no idea but on the
desktop version it's there so I would
recommend going to the desktop version
downloading it using it there get a
sense get a feel of how this app works
and then use it on the iPad Pro also in
terms of color grading a lot of those
features that you're used to seeing on
the desktop app which are industry
standard Hollywood standard are
available here on the I iPad I Gotta
Give it to Black Magic design out of the
gate they have done a tremendous job
adding a lot of features into this app
Adobe are you hearing us with a
Photoshop and as you've probably seen on
YouTube already there are shortcuts to
unlock pretty much all the features of
DaVinci Resolve however those features
are not always optimized for the iPad as
of yet that's why they were hidden in
the shortcuts menu according to my
sources at Blackmagic design but they
could come in the future depending if
there's a need and if there is a desire
for it now I'm not going to go through
how to edit everything on this because
there are plenty of tutorial videos out
there for that but I'm going to
highlight some of the features that I
think are really cool that may get you
into DaVinci Resolve and go wait a
second should I put you know Premiere
aside or maybe even Final Cut Pro now I
personally am a Final Cut Pro editor but
Final Cut Pro does have some limitations
that DaVinci has addressed and
especially on the iPad app and then
after that we'll come to my final
thoughts about this what's it like
editing on an iPad or is it better
suited for the desktop so with that
let's jump into DaVinci Resolve right
now so now we're gonna open up DaVinci
Resolve here on the iPad taking look at
this real quick this is going to look
exactly pretty much exactly like the
desktop version of course you do not
have your top menu bar that you normally
have on your desktop but pretty much
everything else is there now here's the
thing about a DaVinci Resolve iPad is
that while it looks very much like
DaVinci Resolve if you're new to this
program there is no way to hover on
anything you have to tap on every item
and you don't know what
anything is unless you tap on it now you
do have your cut page and then also you
have your grading page for colors and so
forth which is the industry standard
here is a couple of the issues with
DaVinci Resolve when it comes to this
cut page I can't zoom in I'm using my
fingers to zoom in I can't at all I
would actually need the edit page which
you can access through shortcuts and
I'll show you that in just a second but
as it stands right here I see the
waveform bar with my audio but that's it
I don't see everything else so if I want
to zoom in and do a micro cut on
something it's very difficult to do that
at this point in time of course when you
do have the edit page you can get that
and do that very very easily but to
their credit you have this top timeline
borrower that's kind of everything that
you have there and if you really want to
go to a certain point you can do that
relatively quick and then let's say if I
want to bring this here
to this space I say I want to just cut
this command B then what I do is I hold
this hold this till it's green
this is again where it's a little bit
tricky is I want to take this clip and I
want to move it over here to that
portion and then I could do that so it's
a little bit challenging and if you're
not used to DaVinci result or to this
page you will find this a little bit
different at this point in time now
let's go over to some of the other
aspects of this let's say I want to open
up a project here I can do local network
or cloud and then we have a Blackmagic
Cloud beta which means you can have a
project in the cloud if you're working
on desktop let's say a PC or Mac in your
studio or let's say in your office and
you want to come home and work onto your
iPad as long as you have the media you
can do that now basically I have my
projects here that are been downloaded
and my media I would actually have right
here so I can import media and I have my
Samsung X5 drive right here which has
all my like folders and video footage
that I usually put because I use this
SSD drive as a scratch disk to edit off
of because it's relatively fast and it
works really well on the MacBook Pro so
I usually do that for the most part so
you can also import these files into the
iPad as well if you want to do that if
you want to just have them locally
stored there but you can also edit off
the SSD drive because it is a
thunderbolt connection let's talk about
color on this color is really where a
lot of this is at now what we have is
called nodes and the nodes are right
here okay now you can adjust these how
you want them to be what you can do with
this is you have various different notes
think of it like layers on Photoshop and
a node is a separate layer so let's say
I just want to edit one portion let's
say I want to do visual effects let's
say which I have right here I have uh I
can do let's say I want to do face right
so I just tap in
save face and I'll show you this is
really cool face refinement
so I can take that and I can drag it
onto this which I've already done here
so I'll kind of show you what that looks
like and then I can analyze you have
various different clips so whatever
edits you have done or whatever Cuts you
can select those cuts here so I want to
do this and I want to analyze it
it's going to analyze my face I put a
dynamic zoom on that now I want to zoom
in on this and I want to say okay well
let's go down to here and I can actually
now this is something that's going to
happen with DaVinci Resolve at times
they will hang I've seen a lot of videos
where they say these things don't hang
that hangs it hangs quite a bit at this
current form there needs to be some
updates to fix this this is an M2 iPad
and it hangs all the time which is a bit
frustrating so now I need to reopen it
again and it should be able to work
there we go so this is something you're
gonna have to do a lot especially if
you're editing in 4k so now I can go
into some really cool things I can zoom
in on my face so I can get a little bit
closer now I've done already some
adjustments here but I'm going to show
you a little bit more let's go to eye
retouching here now I can actually do
eye bag removal you see how the eyes how
it's changed it
is brighten them up a little bit
highlight I want to add a little more
brightness to the eyes brighten up the
whites there it can look a little fake
so you have to be very uh you know just
adjusted accordingly sharpen the eyes a
bit now I'm going to do shine removal on
the skin let's say You're really sweaty
or oily you want to reduce some of that
you can do that there naturally and it's
already tracked my entire face so then
when I go back and I play this
what's going on guys
now it's going to take some time to re
uh to render this okay now when the box
is red it's rendering it now it does
take some time it takes a long time to
render these effects but this is very
cool that you can actually do face
refinement so if I'm doing a sitting
talking video like I'm doing right here
for a lot of my videos I can do this in
a tracks and it looks absolutely natural
s lens so that is zoomed in and we go
back zoom out again
actual that looks absolutely amazing now
right here I have what's called my color
grading here and I've adjusted this a
little bit here in terms of the contrast
the pivot the details and you can do a
lot of these things HDR you can do
curves you can do the warp Hue
saturation tool which is fantastic so I
can just kind of adjust this and you can
do this clip by clip and then of course
you can copy and paste this so making
sure everything goes accordingly but
color on
DaVinci Resolve is the industry standard
out there and it's beautiful but get it
but again this is the problem that we're
going to have here and hopefully they do
resolve this is I have no idea what any
of these icons are unless I tap and even
then when I tap I might not know how to
use them so it'd be great if there was a
tutorial out there and of course there's
a lot of them on uh in terms of YouTube
you can find a ton of tutorials on how
to grade and how to edit on DaVinci
Resolve but being that it's an iPad app
it would be nice if it had a little bit
more of a user-friendly interface in
terms of highlighting telling you to
know what this title what this does
versus that does like for example you
can do your keys on this you can do
masking you can mask an object here so I
can say well uh yeah I mean there's a
lot of things you can do and it just
takes some time to learn it but I think
the Space refinement is really cool now
if we go back to here we also have a
transition so if you're looking for
transitions for editing there's a ton of
them here a lot that's already built
into this which is fantastic to have and
then we can go into titles if you're
looking for titles you can adjust does
that accordingly
and what the great thing about the hover
tool on the iPad Pro the M2 with the
pencil is I'm getting a sense of what it
looks like so I'm just hovering with the
pencil right here and I'm getting a
sense of what these titles will look
like which is really really cool this is
one of the benefits of the M2 versus the
M1 now if I want to export of course
it's relatively simple in this way I can
tap on this to uh you know sign into my
various Publications on that but if I
wanted to say h.264 h.265 I can export
it it'll tell me where to export now
here's the thing with this you cannot
export to your photos app as of right
now lumafusion other applications out
there allow you to do that DaVinci
Resolve does not this is something I did
feedback to them and they said that they
would possibly put that out there in the
near future so you probably heard that
there are some shortcuts to open up more
features on DaVinci Resolve and I will
show you what that is now option command
K opens up your keyboard customization
shortcuts menu here now you've got a lot
of options here that you can play with
but I want to show you down here what
everybody's talking about when you're
looking on YouTube and that is to show
page okay so you click on this easier to
use it with the pencil and as you can
see we got cut deliver edit fairlight
fusion and media all here and I beside
shortcuts to this already because here
we just have our cut and color grading
here but now we have everything that's
available here so case in point I can
see all these items starting to pop up
here as I'm
opening up these icons so we've got
these two and now we've got the edit and
we've got the cut the edit is much
easier because you can zoom in on the
timeline as you normally would but it's
not magnetic like Final Cut Pro so just
keep that in mind then of course we have
in terms of you know we want to do some
very cool things in terms of fusion and
fair light and audio and deliver and all
the great things all that's here so you
have more features and more
functionality here but the downside of
it is is that these are not ready for
prime time yet according to Blackmagic
in Singapore so they're kind of hidden
in the shortcuts menu you can play with
them if you want but I probably wouldn't
rely on a full project with them as of
yet but they are there to have some fun
with and I'm definitely excited for this
because this makes editing so much
easier between the two but now this
brings us to the question editing on an
iPad in DaVinci Resolve it's great it's
fun but to be honest with you I need a
larger display maybe you can edit on a
iPad display and they're beautiful and
and the responsive and they're great but
when right now where you're not able to
really zoom in on the timeline as much
as you would like to to really see your
waveforms and to see those finite cuts
it makes it a little bit cumbersome
right now then also the same time the
icons while they are touch there's these
long presses that you don't know when in
the long press and when not to and then
you're selecting things some things
aren't as responsive as they can be and
that's why I was a little bit hesitant
to give you a review right out the gate
because you know the black magic design
is going to update this and they are
going to improve this but seeing the
color grading seeing the AI seeing the
title effects seeing the effects that
you can do already that are built into
this it makes it pretty damn amazing
those are my thoughts on DaVinci Resolve
for the iPad I think it's worth
investing if you are into these kind of
things but if you're looking to just
play around a little bit then maybe
lumafusion might be the better option
for you in the meantime until they sort
of work out the Kinks and the bugs but
overall impressive job by black magic
design hit that like button that
notification Bell and check out more of
our reviews right here
foreign
[Music]